[Music]
welcome to hot seat we're with the show
with the hottest seat on all of youtube
i gotta practice dude
today's sacrifice to the hot seat gods
is gilbert gallon
another i guess we're the hottie gods
i will start off with a slightly cooler
question
people see you on tiger belly how did
you meet bobby and how did you end up
being on that show i met bobby through
kalila so i met kalila at a coffee uh
was it coffee bean did you mean a tea
leaf
yes i read his biography before he came
out
it's in my wikipedia where i met her we
talked about mma she's filipino our
mutual friend said hey gilbert does tech
stuff which i don't i just do self tapes
for an actor she thought i did audio
she's like hey can you come help me do
this podcast with my boyfriend like i'll
help you push star that's all i know how
to do and she's like hey cool he's bobby
lee i was like okay what the [ __ ] and
then we started how did you make it i
thought you guys were siblings when i
first i honestly thought too like
siblings were cousins a lot of people
were cousins but how did you meet kalila
uh at the coffee shop no like you just
randomly you're just talking no our
friends was like hey me like she was
with her friend jenna you know jenna
have you oh yeah jenna came here oh yeah
jenna was like we were friends from
chicago she goes hey i'm having to talk
to my friend i want you to meet her and
we started talking about mma and then
she's like i also have a podcast can you
help me get it going
and then i had to learn everything on
youtube what was your first day like
working with him so he's the tech guy
that never did tech before they called
me audio engineer because they had a i
think they had a white guy prior to that
and
what would
so they're racist they kicked out the
white guy and they wanted a filipino
what are the reasons take the shoes off
he didn't take what they didn't say he
didn't take his shoes off
he didn't take his shoes off so he got
fired and he also also he charged like
he also charged like five thousand
dollars and i was free oh okay maybe
that's the difference that's probably
yeah who's [ __ ] winning now huh i
take my shoes off slightly warmer
question what's the weirdest [ __ ] you've
ever seen bobby lee do uh not weird
anymore because i've learned how to
navigate it now but i was very shocked
when he put his penis on my elbow uh and
then he goes like
first met him but now off camera wasn't
out was it out what's that when's the
first time you saw his dick probably
within the first two weeks when's the
last time he saw his dick yesterday last
two weeks two three weeks three weeks
but now the thing is he tries to make
people uncomfortable then you go for
grabbing and he freaks out gonna stop so
if you make it uncomfortable for him
he's stuck also if you like giving him a
hand job he's like no this isn't what i
really wanted he's like dude this is
weird stop yeah well he's like yes
most embarrassing thing you ever done uh
i pooed my pants in second grade miss
bender's class outside but there was a
there's a bunch of dogs that day was one
of those like a bunch of dogs are here
all the kids can play with them so i
faked it and said oh i slept in dog poo
i'm like oh that sucks gilbert go clean
it off i went to the bathroom
pretended i was wiping off my shoe but i
still smell like [ __ ] so people started
realizing oh you should've spammed but i
kept going [ __ ] i can't get this off my
screen what the hell's going on improv
that's it there's dookie all over your
pants but the smell of the shoe is
coming from your crotch i know but
people weren't smoking my crotch but i
had to explain like god i can't get it
all anyone else smelling [ __ ] god it
smells like human [ __ ]
it smells like human [ __ ] though i kept
doubling down so i kept i would like
just throughout the class i'd be like
the best man i'm so sorry i can't
believe it's like why did we play today
with the dog bringing it up all the time
nobody's saying anything and this
[ __ ] second grader's like hey guys
sorry guys i can't get the [ __ ] oh
good lord it smells like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
who is that bro
did you start blaming people around you
rachel you [ __ ] [ __ ] yourself i
didn't do second city yet because i
wasn't saying great i i did not yes and
it was just the one thing the dogs guys
the dog
you're so happy dude come on i know
right you didn't know how to [ __ ]
escalate them like the dogs dripping
drippity cheese
build this classroom on a toilet
cemetery
good lord we're dudes you just get this
look to like the end of the day people
are like it was you
did you ever have any crushes on your
teachers uh
yeah that one describe your hottest
teacher miss verhoeven first grade and
that's very good that's all mistakes era
dude the finest titties in the class
last time you jacked off into what porn
video uh
uh it's called sometimes it's branded as
prg taxi or czech taxiport oh i like
that guy is this some stevie wiebe what
is this is that tucked up patrol part
two do you taxi porn people watch taxi
porn taxi porn it's is that a bing bus
check no no it's check that out
there was once i was watching a porn
this was weird and i was like is that
vitality from youtube
it was he did that first you know that
before youtube he did that first guy
yeah
hey see what are we doing here david you
said this is your favorite video
no i've never seen anyone pick the one
pick the one that you are are you pretty
horny now oh that's no that's fake wait
you said use a taxi video no but that
when it's something called fake rub it's
it gets i'm out of it oh yeah there's
too much branding in the car let's stay
authentic to what he watches and just
find the right video okay which one is
it it's called check taxi for i said
check
oh i know i think it's checked by czech
republic yeah not check it with a ch
only likes eastern european ch or cz
where are we at cg right like czech
republic yeah yeah yeah it's a beaut
prague is beautiful dude i heard they
got a lot of sex trafficking there they
do you know you know in prague you know
i'm probably the czech republic their
legal age for people to have sex is 14.
wow how do you know that because 14 year
old girls when me and my son went to go
teach there like literally 14 or 15 year
old girls started to like be really
weird with us at the bar and we're like
no this is weird why are they at the bar
you're allowed at the bar too not 21.
drinking age 14. i did see hella young
people though when i was at the clubs
there and they were literally like it's
okay at age they were maybe like 16 or
17 and we're like no this is weird
they're like no it's okay at 14 here
we're like it's not okay here she's like
i've been [ __ ] it's not okay in my
mind
yeah they've been [ __ ] for a long
time yeah i mean this guy gilbert hey
gilbert what's what's the most recent
point
that what's the most uh the most recent
rim 4k
ram 4k
three fingers of the guy's butt we're in
4k oh i don't like the butt penetration
that's not for me that's not for this i
like rim 4k isn't that around but i
don't like the boots
so the most recent point you've seen is
a guy getting rim job and getting
fingered his butt whoa dude that's when
i click off kind of [ __ ] up for you to
watch this is a stretch nick has made me
do before training oh yeah it's for your
hips what's the weird
hip flexors what's the weirdest place
you jacked off at
uh
in the car lax picking up a friend
while you're picking him up or just
before just before is the friend of
chicker dude we don't know were you
parked
were you parked i said we don't know why
assuming things i don't know
where you parked
the park
around from like all the turbos going
that'd be a nightmare that's truly a
nightmare
if you ever driven through lax you know
that's a [ __ ] the sickest part was
passing tom bradley tom brown
where did you not where did you not uh i
think it was a
yellow
no no it wasn't a terminal hawaiian air
on the side next to the yellow no not
even at the airport like the park and go
the yellow and black one oh parking goes
a good place to nut park and go yeah
parking go i paid to go in we're now
it's the uber place right yeah
hey
hey room 4k answer the question taste
position when they got in the car were
they asking you why you're so out of
breath or while i was like it smells
like bleaching i was out of breath it
might just smell like bleach wait what
did you come in the day
did you come in a cup play lava
yeah did you come in yeah what did you
do come in a cup like where did you come
on the seat though
how do you come on a seat belt is this a
rental i didn't plan for it guys
i just doing the you know doing the
thing and it landed perfectly on the
diagonal and what did you smear it into
the seat belt no i took the seatbelt off
i went to in and out right there before
i got a napkin i know that in and out
let's edit it out
[ __ ] that dude we're for sure i'm gonna
podcast not jk news which is more
reputable you're in the hospital you're
also hot
what inspired you to get horny or
whatever did it inspire you yeah can i
tell you what what do you think i was
watching porn no but what kind of this
one
they're like okay wait wait wait wait
wait no context we need contacts
you you [ __ ] came in you came you're
parked at the l at the park and go right
and you're bored just watching it park
and go i mean i get it i was just i
think i had watched it like the week and
you're just like oh i gotta watch that
[ __ ] again this was like one of those
like friendly like i'll pick you up at 2
am so i'm like so you had you had a
spank bank in your head
so people listen to joe rogan when
they're waiting for the people in the
world when they jerk off no when they're
picking up people in the airport in the
car i get it well so but i didn't know
it was 2am that's a different story now
because i was going to ask you next what
if people see you [ __ ] beating away
it's like i want to get there early i
wanted to rest and i was like yo i got
that nut too yeah
get it out did you have a napkin ready
to go or you just [ __ ] no you went
out oh it's in and out no no but how
like with a boner tucked into my
skinny jeans it's good
and i had to balance the seat belt so it
wouldn't drip off the boner didn't go
away drippity drippity drippity [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] today's video is brought to you
by babel the number one selling language
learning app it is pretty amazing
because me myself i want to be a polygon
and i'm starting my journey with a
babble
learning language is really hard i
remember taking spanish in high school
and you always learn the words that
don't really matter like a building or
you learn like park bench and you're
like what am i ever going to use these
words what i like about babel since it's
developed by over a hundred language
experts they're trying to get you into
conversation as soon as possible it's
pretty simple because these lessons are
like in 15 minutes that you could be on
the go you could listen in the train and
the bus in the car and your uber it
doesn't matter because it's real quick
you could even take a dookie on a
spanish toilet and learn spanish
and one thing i also like is they got
speech recognition technology so you
know sometimes you're practicing on your
own over and over and you're saying it
wrong well you could say it into it and
you'll get corrected on the annunciation
also you could choose from like 14
different languages they got spanish
they got german man they got french they
got so many cool languages so if you
want to learn another language go to
babel cause they got a really good deal
right now when you get a three-month
subscription you get another three
months for free that's six months for
the price of three go to babel.com
that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com and use the promo code
off the record to get the special deal
that's babel.com b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
with the promo code off the record
punchline we've now hit the 10-minute
mark this is part of the hot seat where
we like to get real personal really
first okay oh wait real quick though but
uh do you have a question i do oh go
ahead who broke your heart and how did
they do it [ __ ] uh
let us get serious folk
band camp was one of them you wait you
went to real band camp i thought that
was an american pie legend
let me start how sad this is so i was
like 230 pounds in high school i was a
sophomore and then i didn't have a lot
of friends but at band camp i remember
uh i became way too comfortable letting
people call me fat and laugh about it
and so all these guys started like
making a thing where they started doing
sketches at the talent show about
gilbert being fat oh my god
and they did a whole sketch about you
stuff like that or like and like the
cafeteria i'd sit with them like they're
my friends and they always call my mom
at triplexfatty.com
hey guys i'm laughing oh my god like
where's your mom's face holy [ __ ] i came
out of nowhere no but they used to sue
because i was like can you look that up
uh triplexmaddy.com check out rim 4k
that's a good time to be honest suddenly
i really suddenly i relate to you on the
human level way more you would always be
like did we be and then you were fat too
yeah it was like oh expanding.com is out
where your mom's now you and your fat
mom hang out i'll be like high five like
i'm a member
and this is the first time i was like i
think i actually was sad about it i
remember like skipping the like the
planned activities to go to my dorm so i
remember just sitting in the bed
crying but i didn't want people to hear
me so i locked the door and i played
sean paul's what's that album that came
out uh they caught me button naked
you're just crying your ass off to give
me the light just give me the light
think about that playing lock the door i
kept going like wow so fat triple looks
fabulous it's a movie scene dude but
wait that is that what made you go i'ma
lose this [ __ ] we're starting this
was junior year again who broke your
heart though where's that chicken boy i
was just saying because it's also
happened at bandcamp so that happened
yeah and the girl
shout out to elena steiner [ __ ] you up
first and last name let's go
what's her instagram sorry not that's
steiner is a great human being uh
san antonio this is jake i had talked
with her i became the bff on the phones
like leading up to bandcamp every night
calling her friend-zoned thinking i was
like making headway yeah and i kept
trying like i like this girl i was here
i'm gonna i'm gonna see this chatting as
girlfriends dude i'm gonna see this girl
at band camp oh i'm gonna like do this
thing to her she's like oh my god i
can't wait let me know i'm like it's
gonna hurt she's gonna love it
then i get to band bandcamp we're at the
dance and the whole thing i kept telling
was like i'm gonna like oh you're gonna
see me talk to the girl at the dance and
i'm gonna kiss her and i also brought a
confetti thingy to shoot you oh wait
wait after you kissed her my god who's
gonna do it that'd kiss her
i was that i was that feels boy that
loved watching all the rom-coms i was
like this might just how you do it you
were unhorny i i was no i was very horny
he was really good he jacks off at the
airport
let's not make that a thing
terminal two we know like one time
i went to go see her i was like the last
i was such a push i was okay like i kept
saying it's gonna be this day it's gonna
be this slow dance it's like [ __ ] it was
the last one did you start shivering and
[ __ ] i was a little nervous what song
was it what song does it give us the
energy it goes just give it up but like
a very slow voice just give me
you think that your ancestors would just
[ __ ] murder you if they heard the
skin
or maybe they're inspired i feel like my
grandfather would just [ __ ] strangle
me filipinos are like you could have
done better you've done more yeah you
could have done more than you walked up
to her you kissed her i was like hey
it's the last dance and i was like i
think i don't remember i'm like
traumatized you just shoot the confetti
in her face and [ __ ] her [ __ ]
the whole time she's like hey are you
gonna go say what's up to this girl i
think i made eye contact i was like
hates the last dance i like brought her
over and you were still 230 pounds at
this point really fast also just had
people call me triplex fatty for the
past two days.com i cried keep my i
cried to sean paul just give it a like
and then uh yeah and she's like who's
the girl i'm like you and i just had a
dance with her like this is the dance oh
no i know and what was she like and then
she was like oh
let's dance
and then she's like um
we like get it do you get it she's like
dude you're like my home girl like what
the [ __ ] and then i just shot the
confetti
what and then she's like what are you
doing and i was like
and she's like um let's just walk back i
think it's done
and that was it you shot the confetti
and she said what are you doing yeah and
then uh that's [ __ ] rude bro hey
thank you for sharing bro
that was the catalyst i think the
following year [ __ ] feel for you
right now is that when you said i'm
gonna join sport karate you know i was
already doing that oh god that's right
doing mortal kombat wait as a fat dude
that's a fat dude oh [ __ ] now it's even
funnier placing on the top three six wow
oh [ __ ] uh wait so that but that was the
catalyst for like the senior year i lost
a bunch of weight started wearing
american eagle because i used to only
wear polo shirts in like dockers sperrys
american eagles
and then uh yeah that's when i was like
i became like a pickup artist and i did
p90x when i first came out peanut x dude
tony horton is he dad we don't know so
was this high school for you i think he
died doing p90x
he did it too much
that was the real deal i'm so happy you
told me that story man but also
i still remember triple x fatty what a
great story triple x fatty no thank you
for that because
i already thought you were a [ __ ]
loser but now even
harder we see it it's even now i'm just
kidding nah it's [ __ ] cool because
it's like you see the full circle that's
right you kind of see like the catalyst
to what made gil who he is today but
like even after that i lost the weight
but i still had this weird confidence
where it's like so fake and that's what
got me into pickup artists when i
actually did pua because what's simple
pick up those guys oh
they watched their videos and i torented
their all their programs did you see
when we went [ __ ] work though did you
see the video that we went we went to
ucla to get a [ __ ] pokemon girls i
would just start cracking up because i i
just suck at pranks and [ __ ] and i can't
i always break character so i'm like can
i get your number
dude
because he's special
the game was he's like your number
just rolling
no the game was so god [ __ ] what i know
this is still odd you're in the hot seat
answer the question
bro
tayden is tearing yeah that's how it
goes that's what you like you said yeah
dude you're the one that's pissed get me
a seat belt so i can show you
real confidence after watching like
cymbal pickup and all these guys simple
pickup was interesting i would sell
people because this was in chicago so i
still became i lost the weight but then
i gained it all back because i became
friendzoned again it was it was a
physical change happened but that didn't
change outlook with women damn so the
change was i was i always tell people
the story i remember being in my room uh
in chicago after it was like i was like
19. or sorry 20 and i was holding a
crunchwrap supreme because there was a
taco bell and i said i was naked
delicious and i was watching porn and i
remember being like what the [ __ ] am i
doing while you're eating like a country
improv all these girls keep friendzoning
me i'm eating a country after pre-i
gained all my weight back back to 2 40 2
30 because i'm drinking beer all the
time and i'm watching porn and i was
like i
kept eating the crunchwrap supreme
i'm not going to throw it away for the
packaging i had my moment changed and i
was like i'll still eat this that sounds
like a fun life though dude you're just
eating then i was like all i typed from
youtube was how to kiss a girl and the
first thing came up wasn't simple pick
up it was some other guy who straight up
just talked to a girl
didn't touch her doing anything and then
got her number and kissed her and i was
like all he did was it was just funny he
was talking to her yeah and very
intentional so i started going at deep
dive into like most of the youtube guys
that i pick up are she like and i saw
the three asian guys doing i was like
holy [ __ ]
these guys are doing it was being silly
so i just i was writing comics so i just
started doing that just girls in class
and just they didn't have a creepy like
approach to their thing there were some
videos i found some guys i'm like
they're pretty much canceled now because
like there's some like rainbow vibes
that's over yeah everyone doing it now
is the creepiest [ __ ] i've ever
seen it's okay if it's the best but what
it taught me was just confidence of just
being silly yeah because they would they
would have games that's what i really
liked about it is like they'll they'll
be like do it with rap lyrics or pick up
girls i was like you know like the show
right now like impractical losers
impractical jokes
i don't hate them
impactful jokers
losers
my favorite one is they would dress up
like pokemon
and then they would go talk to girls
gonna talk to hot ass tricks too yeah
that was hilarious i would literally
just copy their jokes there's the
dumbest ones ahead and just say it and
not break eye contact and girls
they would fall for it it's crazy and
fast forward to today
you're married right i was engaged
actually
i was thinking a hardcore phase back in
l.a got depressed i went back into pick
up artistry where i was basically just
like ranting and ramping around town
just going back talking like we call
machine gunning we go to a bar and talk
to every single girl don't call machine
gunning anymore yeah hey please don't i
like it says we call it machine gun yeah
like it's a community
artist guys we
i met her at a bar i was actually
bazooka
that's anthony's style bro but dude i
was doing that she had a bar i did it to
her i was at a wrap party for a pilot i
was in and then she like denied me on
everything i was i'm gonna keep talking
this girl and that's stopped doing a
pickup artistry there and then
you're like i'm gonna stop shooting up
bars dude i'm tired of doing this
she's gonna get all up yeah but you're
but you're simple i always wanted to
meet those guys and yeah about this but
you're engaged now so this is the the
full story of
of
heartbroken
to now dude
that's a straight-up movie though being
fat at bandcamp crying to sean paul to
getting married we're gonna skip the
country supreme dude no no that's in the
middle i'm just yeah yeah by the way
simple darkest night right there simple
pickup came out as gay all of them
really that's all you know they did it
dude i i think i think you're right they
all did yeah they're all different right
but aren't they i heard i read this i
read you guys are friends i heard that
you guys are like this weird legal [ __ ]
right now is that true i don't know i
haven't talked to makeup artists guys
they actually broke up so i don't know
what they all do
but i know one of them is like a
creative agency that helps people shoot
commercials and brand and i think some
of them really got into crypto so they
all kind of are started doing their own
yeah uh yeah no it says that they all
had a pack that they wouldn't be gay
that so they're suing each other why are
you pretending you're looking at
articles
[Music]
you